so you're bringing an android back to
life
no
that would likely be impossible
but i have made some fascinating
discoveries regarding synthetic
botanicals
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
raised by wolves season two the first
two episodes debuted together and i'll
be discussing both the collective and
seven in this video to me this almost
felt like a new story in the same world
rather than a continuation of where
things left off at the end of season one
partly because the conditions are much
different in the tropical zone and we
get introduced to a slew of new
characters there are hints at all those
unresolved mysteries that have been
floating around but as i recap things
i'll be focusing more on what's new for
season two since there's a lot to keep
track of at the end i'll give you my
thoughts about the new season and where
i think things are heading before we
dive in though i have to give you a
quick spoiler warning if you haven't
watched raised by wolves season 2
episodes 1 and 2 then this video won't
be for you and with that out of the way
let's get into it
episode 1 opens with a powered down
mother being discovered in the jungle of
the tropical zone on kepler-22b
you'll learn later that about six months
have passed since they bailed out of the
ship that they passed through the
planet's core in at the end of the first
season remember the tropical zone was on
the other side of the planet from where
mother and father initially landed it's
protected by an electromagnetic field
and the voice that paul was hearing
which he thought was soul wanted him to
stay away from it this will make sense
later and serve as a clue as to what's
going on with the voice so i will come
back to that in this sequence where they
collect mother and father to bring them
back to the atheist arc that arrived in
the closing moments of season one we
meet several new characters tamara lane
is an atheist soldier who is skeptical
of the a.i that is guiding their group
which is called the collective decima is
a methodic engineer who was working on
the ark before the atheists stole it and
she has an android with her name virile
who will learn is a replacement for her
daughter that died there's also an
atheist named cleaver who in contrast to
tamerlane seems absolutely loyal to the
ai even going as far as saying he'd be
fine with taking orders from it for the
rest of his life you're introduced to
the trust after mother wakes up to find
a tech rooting around inside her abdomen
she demands to be taken to him after she
takes control of the situation and
here's the ai call to her because it was
also created by campion sturgis it calls
her sister and they seem to get along
swimmingly it notices she has some
encrypted files hidden inside of her
memory and she explains that she feels
things impulses and one of those is to
conceal the parts of herself that
displease her she asked about number
seven the android serpent hybrid she
gave birth to and the trust thinks that
since the lander was destroyed anything
inside would have been two though as
viewers we know this isn't the case
mother learns that all of the children
have been rescued and that thanks to her
all that remains of the mithraic threat
is a lone terrorist he's referring to
marcus who starts out the season 3 000
miles away where he shoots down a ship
and then tries to use that to attack the
ark the trust takes control of the ship
before he can do that and then he shoots
the controls which causes him to crash
into the ocean which is unfortunate
since it's actually filled with acid
he's able to escape and while he's
wandering around he finds some of those
metal cards with the symbols on them
that we saw a couple of times in season
one remember mother had her vision of
the ancient ceremony when she scanned
one of those marcus eventually finds a
cave and is surprised to find that there
is a temple inside dedicated to soul
this all feeds into a sense that he's
being guided by the deity later when
he's out gathering food he sees decima
and varial trying to escape from the
collective they had those bomb packs
strapped to them and the other prisoner
who told them that he knew how to remove
them tried to take his off it detonated
luckily marcus knows that an android
shoulder pin looks the same as a pack
key so he digs out varials and uses it
to free them because of his
well-documented hatred for them he did
want to leave the android behind but
decimal was able to convince him to free
them both he brings them back to his
cave and explains that soul wants him to
fill the temple with believers
mother and father are reunited with the
children paul was kept a little longer
because they quarantined him after they
found out he was hearing voices the kids
are split on being part of this atheist
colony and the members don't really want
them there either they tend to blame the
two mythic made androids and their
adopted mythic children for destroying
earth during the war the trust explains
that mother has been reprogrammed to
fight for them but the colonists have
good reasons to be wary of necromancers
even though lamia doesn't have her eyes
to weaponize her beyond that this is a
big upgrade from their old settlement
the weather is good food is plentiful
they have a nice dwelling to stay in and
as father says this side of the planet
is less intent on trying to kill their
children there's still some weirdness
between mother and father remember he
started to have human-like feelings that
resembled jealousy when he found out she
got pregnant but he's decided to
postpone the erasing of his memories of
their time together paul doesn't want
sue around so she decides to get
reassigned to a different group when
mother questions her on why she decided
to tell him about killing his real
parents she explains that she didn't
that a voice inside his head told him
the truth mother mentions what happened
to her inside the sim vaguely and
wonders if this is a transmission
capable of affecting humans and androids
this set sue on a path to try to figure
out where the voice is coming from you
learn that the trust plans out
everything for the colonists and they
each get daily tasks and you also see
that there are punishments the kids and
father all get the task of gathering
food while mother is assigned to the
nursery while they're gathering father
and vita find a cave where inside they
find pieces of an ancient android paul
finds a dodecahedron under a tree and
campion finds an egg the artifact has
the tree of life symbol so the prophecy
of the orphan boy is brought up talk of
the pentagonal prophecy in the tree of
life leads to a discussion over saul
which they both agree exists at least as
far as the voice that everyone is
hearing but campion thinks that it's
evil because it would be against the
rules to keep what they found they make
a pact to keep each other's secrets
later when they're looking at them at
home paul says he thinks there might be
a map or seeds inside to grow the tree
he's thinking that maybe it hasn't been
planted yet and while they're talking
someone comes up and burns the soul
symbol outside of their dwelling as a
threat and the first episode ends there
episode 2 opens with marcus sitting by
the water and we see decima come up to
sit by him she prays and then she says
that she can feel soul's light burning
inside of him that he's the only human
being that she's ever wanted to touch
this is all likely because he has
mother's necromancer eyes inside of him
but he never tells anybody about what's
going on after she hears what happens
sue brings the kids a gun for protection
after they leave she tells mother that
she found out that there is a signal but
that it can't penetrate the emf that
covers the tropical zone they don't know
where the transmission is coming from
but this leads her to believe that they
may be safest right where they're at
when mother goes to the nursery she
learns that the trust has a different
assignment for her she has to be the
punisher for the day she has to wear
this suit that they found on the ark to
conceal her identity and then after she
puts on the disguise she has to go into
a room and beat tamerlane this
traumatizes her and when she goes to
tell father she sees that he's collected
a lot of pieces of this ancient android
and he says that they date back nearly a
million years when he exposed them to
light berry started to grow on them
which set up what was probably my
favorite father line of the episodes
when he said that he made some
fascinating discoveries regarding
synthetic botanicals mother explains
that she had to punish the person that
set the fire and father is just
delighted that there's justice in this
place even for them he tells her that
his caregiving protocols are satisfied
like never before and they agree that
they're in sync in that regard mother
brings up that she wants champion to be
the one to take the baton when the trust
is ready to hand over control father is
concerned that this desire might be
related to what happened with number
seven
while they're having dinner tempest
mentions that she's thinking of having
her child raised with the others in the
collective their meal is interrupted by
tamerlane who as part of his punishment
has to come to personally express
remorse about the fire his injuries are
serious so when champion sees them he
decides that he better come clean with
mother and father about the things
they'd been hiding in their room he
knows this is going to make paul upset
so mother agrees to say that she found
it on her own and she tells him to
return the egg to its nest while he's
doing that number 7 shows up and
approaches him he ends up falling and
gets knocked out so when mother comes
looking she sees the snake hovering over
his body she scares it away and after it
leaves you see that she does the robot
version of lactating after being close
to him as it's flying away it scares the
colonists who rush to hide in a shed
they close the door and won't let the
kids and father come inside with them
father notices something is in the water
and then the shed gets pulled in this
leads them to believe that number seven
can survive in the acid water and that
it is out to kill them marcus has his
first true believer in decima she
believes in his dream which is
essentially to start a new congregation
of soul believers that are like a family
rather than what the methodic churches
were like on earth she mentions that she
hasn't felt this good since before her
daughter died and he shows her the metal
cards he found she explains that they
could contain data so they have to find
some that aren't damaged tamerlane
decides to escape and they find him near
the water they invite him back to the
cave and they get there just as the tide
is coming in that catches the two
atheists that were following him and
kills them they end up bonding because
they both grew up as child soldiers and
marcus lays out his plan for their new
family he also tells him that it was a
robot who punished him based on the
precision and they realized that it was
mother the next morning the atheists all
get together to hunt number seven
campion thinks it's innocent and might
be a baby and paul thinks it might be
from scripture sue has a conversation
with cleaver and gets some insight into
why he believes in the trust he doesn't
believe it makes mistakes and sees it as
superior to the human commanders he
fought under father learns that his task
is to be a shepherd for the bait squad
the mithraics from season one are now
prisoners and they're all wearing bomb
packs he's supposed to lead them in
hopes that number seven will try to eat
them and then he can detonate them
mother goes to sue to try to have her
duck sealed and you can see that she's
conflicted with what she has to do she
thinks number seven could be a threat to
her children and that means she should
kill it but as its parents she feels
protective at the same time while the
hunt is going on marcus and his group
decide to try to get their hands on a
tank their plan works but he's upset
when he has to kill the atheists inside
he feels like he failed because he's
supposed to convert them not kill them
when they find out that they were
hunting a serpent they also think it
might be a sign from saul or related to
prophecy virile gets overloaded so she
gets sent home alone on the way she's
attacked by a different tank and that
shoots her in the leg she runs into
campion and pull and asks them to help
her get home paul isn't interested he
wants to leave her but campion seems to
like her so he agrees they take off
together and i suppose that they'll end
up running into marcus in the next
episode this episode ends when mother
finds a skin and says out loud that
number seven is a killer of children and
that he only deserves death so there are
a lot of parallels to this new atheist
colony the way that it's structured
under the ai which is almost like their
god which tells them how to behave what
to do how to act it's not that much
different than the way that the
mithraics follow saul i thought the
transition was pretty jarring between
the finale of season one and the season
two premiere like i said at the
beginning it felt like a different show
to me i guess what i always liked best
was mother and father because i think
the fact that they're not human sets up
a lot of interesting situations the
humans have always been less compelling
and pretty hit or miss as far as whether
i connected with them i also have been
swept up in the mystery the show
presents but towards the end of season 1
it started to feel like they were
continuing to pile a bunch of new ones
on without delivering any meaningful
answers so when they jump into a brand
new location with lots of new human
characters that aren't really that
fleshed out it does feel like it's
getting away from the parts of it that i
enjoyed the most that said there's a lot
of sci-fi potential with the trust and
what's going on in the collective and as
far as the mysteries i do feel like they
have a grand idea planned out they're
working towards something going
somewhere so let's get down into some of
those pits and discover more artifacts
and creatures that are evolving
backwards or whatever's going on there i
like this show when it gets weird and
takes some chances and here in these
episodes it had to do a lot of work with
this shift between episodes 10 and 11.
so i did like that there are a lot of
artifacts laying around that there was
some movement as far as sue knowing that
there's a transmission going out and
then little details like father's
android being a million years old so i'm
still curious to see where it's all
going and even though these weren't my
favorite episodes of the show i do
realize that they had a lot of setting
up to do because of the way that they
structured the story mother being
conflicted makes sense and she is
keeping that all to herself father
absolutely kills me he's by far my
favorite character and i'm really
looking forward to see what happens when
he brings this ancient android back to
life marcus appears to have some powers
or at least something going on after
ingesting the necromancer eyes and
everyone is looking at the prophecies
and applying them however they see fit
and i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you thought about these first two
episodes what are the biggest questions
you have at this point in the story and
what are you hoping to see in the next
episode please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon